-The president threatened Iran
on Twitter over the weekend
as the people around him
seem to push for a conflict.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
You might remember that,
during the 2016 campaign,
Donald Trump pretended
he was the anti-war candidate,
lying about his
position on the Iraq war,
and calling it
a "mistake."
Although,
if you paid close attention,
it really seems like
he had an ulterior motive.
-Obviously, the war in Iraq
was a big, fat mistake, alright?
George Bush made a mistake.
We can make mistakes.
But that one was a beauty.
We should have never
been in Iraq.
We have destabilized
the Middle East.
-Had we not
done anything --
had our politicians gone to
the beach and enjoyed the sun --
we would be in a lot better
position than we are right now.
What we've done
is incredible.
If we would have --
if our presidents
would have just stayed home
and gone to the beach,
or even gone and played golf
every single day --
played two rounds a day,
okay?
-Well, that's one promise
he definitely kept.
I mean...
[ Laughter, applause ]
So, --
So, the president...
The president spent
the 2016 campaign
branding himself
as the anti-war candidate.
And then, on Sunday,
he jumped on Twitter
to threaten a war with Iran --
seemingly out of nowhere.
-Just in to CNN,
President Trump tweeting
this stern warning
to Iran.
"If Iran wants to fight,
that will be the official end
of Iran.
Never threaten
the United States again."
-I can't believe I'm saying
this, but go play golf.
[ Laughter ]
It's actually now
a matter of national security
that we make sure
Trump spends as much time
on the golf course
as possible.
Otherwise,
he'll spend his time
threatening to start wars
on Twitter.
We need one of those
Homeland Security threat meters
that tells us how much golf
he needs to play
based on his mood.
Low -- sit in cart.
Guarded --
driving range.
Elevated -- practice putting
while sitting in cart.
High -- one round with B-list
celebrity, like Kid Rock.
Severe -- two full rounds,
and trick him into thinking
he's trapped in the sand
all day
by tossing a new ball into the
bunker ever time he hits it
until he digs himself a hole
and falls asleep in it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump cast himself as
the anti-war candidate,
and now, he's tweeting
threats of war.
And on top of that, he's
surrounding himself with aides
who have repeatedly
called for war --
like his National Security
Adviser, John Bolton,
who championed
the Iraq War.
Bolton has publicly called
for bombing Iran, North Korea,
and Syria, and a former
Trump Administration official
once told the New Yorker,
"John wants to bomb everyone."
And it's not exactly reassuring
to know that this is the guy
advising Trump, because Trump
is very impressionable.
He's like your dip[bleep] son
who starts hanging around
with a bunch of
high-school burnouts.
"Why do you have
a nose ring,
and where did you get
this bag of weed?"
[ As Trump ]
"John gave it to me,
and I smoked the weed
because John told me
drugs are cool, Mom."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
In fact, Bolton is so pro-war
that Trump said recently
he actually keeps Bolton
in check.
-Are you satisfied
with the advice you receive
from John Bolton?
-Yeah.
John's very good.
John is a, uh...
He has strong views on things,
but that's okay.
I actually temper John, which is
pretty amazing, isn't it?
-Even Trump knows
how crazy it is
that he's
the voice of reason.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, think about
what he's saying there.
That joke only works if everyone
knows Trump is crazy.
He's basically saying,
[ As Trump ]
"Sure, I'm a nutjob,
But you should see
this guy."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
It's like getting...
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's like getting in
a fist fight at a bar
and having it broken up
by Conor McGregor.
[ In Irish accent ] "Guy, guys,
let's settle this with words.
Words, not violence.
And I'm certain
this is how I talk."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Now, it was reported last week
that Trump is actually
frustrated with how quickly
his pro-war advisers,
like Bolton and
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo,
are moving towards
a conflict with Iran.
Trump tried to tamp down
those reports
of in-fighting
within his administration,
tweeting that "different
opinions are expressed,
and I make a decisive
and final decision."
So, there you go. Trump makes
the decisive and final decision.
And yet, he still acts like
he doesn't have control
over his own
administration.
The next day, for example,
he was asked by reporters
outside the White House
if we were headed toward
a war with Iran,
and his response
was not very reassuring.
-Mr. President,
are we going to war with Iran?
-I hope not.
[ Laughter ]
-What ha-- Wait.
What happened to
decisive decisions?
"I hope not" isn't an answer
to war with Iran.
It's an answer to the question
"Do you think it's gonna rain?"
[ Laughter ]
Also, Trump is waiting for the
Swiss delegation in that clip,
but still,
why does he just stand there
in the doorway to
the White House like that?
He's like a retiree
who sits on his porch all day
waiting for the mail
to arrive.
[ As Trump ] "Let's see.
Mail usually comes at noon.
Right now, it's 6:00 a.m.
I'd better get out there."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
The other problem here is,
we don't know whose interests
Trump is serving.
On one hand,
he says he doesn't want war.
But on the other hand, he's
listening to guys like Bolton,
who has openly called
for regime change.
And then, there's Saudi Arabia,
which is fighting a proxy war
with Iran
in the Middle East.
We don't know what Trump's
financial relationship
with Saudi Arabia
is like
because he won't release
his tax returns.
But in the past,
he's bragged about
his financial relationships
with Saudis.
-I love the Saudis.
Many are in this building.
Saudi Arabia -- And I get along
great with all of them.
They buy apartments
from me.
They spend $40 million,
$50 million.
Am I supposed to
dislike them?
I like them
very much.
-"They give me money,
so I like them"
is the literal definition
of bribery.
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump and his team --
Trump and his team...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...they keep sending
mixed signals.
In fact,
it was reported last week
that the intelligence suggests
the U.S. an Iran
might actually be misreading
each other's stoking tensions.
And yet, Trump complained that
it was actually the media
that was getting
the story wrong,
while also bragging that it was
good to keep Iran guessing.
-The president posted,
quote,
"With all the fake
and made-up news out there,
Iran can have no idea
what is actually going on."
-"The fake news media is hurting
our country with its fraudulent
and highly inaccurate
coverage of Iran.
It is scattershot,
poorly sourced,
made up, and dangerous.
At least Iran doesn't know
what to think --
which, at this point,
may very well be a good thing."
-No, it's not.
Unpredictability
is not a good thing.
Unpredictability is one of
the symptoms of rabies.
[ Laughter ]
The fundamental problem
is that Trump has
no consistent worldview, and has
no idea what he's talking about.
He just listens
to the TV.
Trump basically
only hired Bolton
because he saw Bolton
on Fox News all the time.
In fact, Bolton even went
on Fox News last year,
and insisted that the invasion
of Iraq was a success,
it was just everything that came
after it that was bad.
-I think the overthrow
of Saddam Hussein --
that military action --
was a resounding success.
I think the mistakes that were
made subsequently --
setting up the coalition
provisional authority,
and others that
followed from it --
are lessons about what to do
after a regime is overthrown.
-Oh, I see.
So, invading Iraq worked out.
It's just everything that
happened because of it was bad.
That's like if you went
to Vegas, got drunk,
and eloped with first person
you met,
and then said,
"The wedding itself was great.
It's just all the sobering up,
and having no shared interests
beyond alcoholism
that ruined things."
[ Laughter ]
We've been here before. We can't
repeat the same mistakes
that led to
the war in Iraq.
Trump's team seems to be
pushing for a conflict
despite resistance
from basically everybody.
I don't know if they'll succeed,
but all I can say is...
-I hope not.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]